foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
it is bad movies Galore as we encounter
the rottenness of the rotten meaning all
of the movies on this list have a zero
percent on the Tomato Meter that's right
zero zip goose egg
[Applause]
now they also have at least 20 reviews
we wanted to make sure that the movies
were vouching for as the worst reviewed
films have a minimum threshold of
critics reviews so these are The Usual
Suspects from remakes to sequels and
even a few Netflix films
hands up high
oh snap you got to drop on water now
that we have set the mood we are
counting down the worst reviewed movies
of all time ranked by Tomato Meter
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
starting with number 10 dark crimes a
hard-boiled detective becomes suspicious
of an author when the incidents
described in his hit novel resemble the
inner workings of an unsolved murder
starring Jim Carrey Charlotte
gansborough Martin Stokes and directed
by alexandros avranos critics say dark
crimes is a rote unpleasant Thriller
that fails to Parlay its compelling true
story and a committed Jim Carrey
performance into even modest chills
chunk to death using a fisherman's knot
only the killer could know those facts
I think the book is your confession
[Music]
I know he's guilty
just prove it
but you get too close
talk you want Justice this is what they
made me
five girl at least like dogs for what
drives most years
don't forget who you are in this case is
all I have left
he strangled him in what makes you think
the murder even happened
hear the truth
number nine Jaws the Revenge a family of
Widow Ellen Brody has long been plagued
by shark attacks and this unfortunate
Association continues when her son is a
victim of a massive great white now in
morning Ellen goes to visit her other
son Michael in the Bahamas where she
meets the Charming Hoagie Nukem as Ellen
and Hoagie begin a relationship a huge
shark appears off the coast of the
island and Ellen's troubles with great
whites begins again starring Lorraine
Gary Lance guest Michael Kane and
directed by Joseph Sargent critics say a
logical tension free and filled with Cut
Rate special effects Jaws for the
revenge is a sorry chapter in a once
proud franchise
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
number eight the last days of American
Crime
and a woman plan the heist of the
century before a government broadcast
signal wipes out crime forever starring
Edgar Ramirez Michael Pitt Anna Brewster
and directed by Olivier Megaton critics
say this crime is punishment
what boy
Johnny d
I gave you up
for one more taste
Bad Company man
it's Julie Smith
oh
we don't know how much gasoline is on
your lips
to light up
but there's nothing to stop
so if you stay real still maybe this
will burn itself out of your face
number seven gold diggers Calvin and
Leonard Two Broke losers are arrested
for trying to rob Rich old sisters Doris
and Betty now the woman have a change of
heart dropped the charges and invite the
boys over to their mansion Calvin
decides he and Leonard should marry the
women and when they soon die live off
The Inheritance the ladies however run
into their own financial troubles and
wed the boys with plans of murdering
them for insurance money starring Will
Friedle Chris Owen Louis Lasser and
directed by Gary Chrysler critics say
this film aspires to Farley level
offensiveness but the PG-13 rating and a
dearth of decent gags renders gold
diggers tame Toothless and dull
yes
I'm watching
you say I could see you do something
already While We're Young do it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I blacked out jars I could have died
that's it
number six super babies baby geniuses
too
toddlers use their special abilities to
stop a media Mogul from altering the
minds of children starring Jon Voight
Scott Baio Vanessa Angel and directed by
Bob Clark critics say a startling lack
of taste pervades super babies a sequel
offering further proof that bad jokes
still aren't funny when coming from the
mouths of babies
freak
what is your last word
duck
duck is your last word
[Music]
this machine has damaged my leg get him
what are you waiting for
eign
foreign
[Music]
I told you it's too late
now it's over
no
look at that
I want you
play time
number five Pinocchio
a wood carver creates a puppet that
longs to become a real boy starring
nicoletabroski Mino belly and Roberto
benini who also directed the film
critics say Roberto benini misfires
wildly with this adaptation of Pinocchio
and the result is an unfunny poorly made
creepy vanity projector
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
number four Gotti
raised in the streets of New York young
John Gotti found his way into the
gambino crime family eventually having
the boss removed and becoming head of
the powerful family now his wife asked
only one thing from John to never expose
their children to his profession but he
broke the vow and John Jr took his place
as his father's Capo starring John
Travolta Spencer lafranco Pruitt Taylor
Vince and directed by Kevin Connolly
critics say forget about it and if you
have a potential life sentence in this
case it would be imprudent to Grant him
bail thank you Miss jackaloni but you
have not convinced me that Mr Gotti is a
Flight Risk Court grants bail in the
amount of one million dollars your honor
as the court has granted bail for Mr
Gotti we also request that they'll be
set at a reasonable amount for Mr
Johnson your honor we have strong reason
to believe that this defendant's life
will be in serious Jeopardy if he is
granted bail and why would that be
because Wilford Johnson has been a
confidential informant for the FBI for
the past 19 years
[Applause]
in light of that information if
confirmed bail is denied on Johnson
stand strong if I refuse to testify
can I get a pass
I swear it
swearing on your Kid's grave
how am I gonna kill the ghost number
three a thousand words
Jacqueline call is a selfish literary
agent whose fast talking ways allow him
to close any deal his next Target is New
Age Guru Dr sinja but the Savvy doctor
sees right through jack a magical tree
appears in Jack's yard and according to
Dr sinja the tree and Jack are connected
every time Jack says a word a leaf falls
from the tree and when the last Leaf
drops Jack will die with just a thousand
leaves left Jack must learn to curb his
speech or he's a goner starring Eddie
Murphy Kerry Washington Cliff Curtis and
directed by Brian Robbins critics say
dated jokes a thousand words was shot in
2008 and removing Eddie Murphy's voice
his graded comedic asset Dooms is
painful mess from the start seems like
every time I say something
yeah
hello
[Music]
oh
[Music]
I want my baby back baby back baby back
I want my baby back baby back ribs
[Music]
hey how are you doing this
I'm doing nothing
doing this tree are now connected
connected
looks like all your talking is making us
sick my talking is not making me sick
oh really what happens when a tree loses
all its leaves Jack
what are you trying to say singers
it's obvious to me the more you talk the
more leaves fall the sicker you get the
thicker I get so what happens if all the
leaves fall off the tree
that usually means a tree is dead
hey wait a second hold on a second
you're telling me that you think
whatever happens to the tree happens to
me
yes
so I could die
yes but you would die in the most
amazing way possible I could die
or someone could turn you into a coffee
table hey since you know you're a real
funny dude just stand here making jokes
while my life is being controlled by
this magic tree
number two One Missed Call
when Beth Raymond Witnesses the deaths
of two friends she knows there is more
at work than just a tragic coincidence
days before they die both victims hear
their terrifying final moments on cell
phones now though the police think Beth
is crazy detective Jack Anders believes
her together the pair try to unravel the
mystery behind the horrifying messages
before their own phone numbers come up
starring Shannon Sossaman Ed Burns Anna
Claudia tanankon and directed by Eric
valet critics say one of the weakest
entries in the J horror remake
sweepstakes One Missed Call is undone by
Bland performances and Shop worn shocks
foreign
foreign
[Music]
before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the ridiculous six
white knife an orphan raised by Native
Americans discovers that five Outlaws
are actually his half-brothers now
together they set out to save their
Wayward father starring Adam Sandler
Terry Crews Taylor Lautner and directed
by Frank caraci critics say every bit as
lazily offensive as its cast and concept
would suggest the ridiculous 6 is
standard couch fare for Adam Sandler
Fanatics and must avoid viewing for film
enthusiasts of every other persuasion
Frank had taken it all
now I get to take something the lives of
his five
ridiculous Sons
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
my God
he's giving himself
[Applause]
I was just trying to knock him out
Stratton
after the death of his American
counterpart an MI6 agent and his team
must Race Against Time to stop a Madman
from unleashing stolen chemical weapons
starring Dominic Cooper Gemma Chan Tyler
hoakland and directed by Simon West
critics say stratton's action thriller
Ambitions are roundly thwarted by a
derivative story misguided casting and a
low budget feel underscored by
unimpressive set pieces
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
fields
Clairvoyant Femme Fatale Nikola 6 has
been living with a dark premonition of
her impending death by murder as she
begins a tangled love affair with three
uniquely different men one of whom she
knows will be her murderer starring
Amber Heard Billy Bob Thornton Theo
James and directed by Matthew Cullen
critics say London Fields bungles its
beloved Source material and an
intriguingly Eclectic cast leaving
audiences with a would-be neo-noir of
interest only to the morbidly curious
Nicola purposely showed up late to her
dinner with Keith
like bruh
get a [ __ ] menu please
I'm on a special diet
no food
you say we could reason why you're late
what's up for me
you look so handsome
you remind me of the king of Saudi
Arabia
I once slept she said experimentally
with the King of Saudi Arabia
it is men search the entire world for
the most beautiful women alive
people do want value for their money
don't they keep
oh absolutely
absolutely right there the thing about
the King was
the king never slept with the same woman
twice and I was brought to his room he
laid out two lines of the finest cocaine
when I was brought to his room he laid
out the most miraculous panties
knickers
[ __ ]
and finally number one ballistic X
versus sever
haunted by the mysterious death of his
wife Jeremiah X has become a recluse but
the former FBI Manhunter is blackmailed
back into service to track down an
Unstoppable xdia operative codenamed
sever who has kidnapped the young son at
ahead of a secret Committee of
international security agencies starring
Antonio Banderas Lucy Liu Greg Henry and
directed by cows critics say a
startlingly inept film ballistic X vs
sever offers overblown wall-to-wall
action without a hint of wit coherence
style or originality
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that about does it for us be sure to
stay tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes
channel for more of the entertainment
content you love and for even more news
scores and recommendations on the latest
TV shows and movies Go to
rottentomatoes.com until next time I am
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]